[Music]
the ice is typically around five
centimeters when i skate on it
that sound you hear is actually a
combination of two sound it's the sounds
from cracks striking beneath me and the
vibrations within the ice plate itself
sounds like it's something supersonic
meet morgen einer hi i'm morgan einen
he's a mathematician who enjoys riskier
hobbies than most i've been skating on
thin ice for 40 years when he's skating
though he's also listening the thinner
the eyes the higher the pitch
just about when the ice is to break and
that would be about three centimeters
the pitch is at the highest c the
supposedly highest note of the soprano
scene
[Music]
morton relies on his knowledge as a
mathematician to calculate the thickness
of the ice its flexibility and its
temperature many people tend to freak
out when they see us skating on thin ice
but i couldn't be more calm because i
know what i'm doing sometimes the ice is
perfectly clear and i can see fish blow
even a beaver and also free divers
swimming under the ice when morton first
started there wasn't any physics or
scientific information to explain how
thin ice skating is possible he studied
the ice for 10 years every winter to
explain the phenomenon
[Music]
i observed three things with a thin eyes
one is that the eyes bends and the
thinner it is the more advanced the iron
needs to be flexible to support you
second the first crack is a true warning
signal then i know the ice is thin and
when it gets even thinner more cracks
evolve and finally the eyes gives
sonorous tone beautiful eerie tone which
immediately tells me how thick the ice
is it's called the coincidence frequency
and it can be calculated mathematically
morton has skated on over 1800 bodies of
water in north america norway and
central and eastern europe
i love skating for the excitement and
challenges it brings it's an opportunity
for math and nature to come together and
make it understandable for me i've been
skating most of my life and i always
look forward to next winter